NASDAQ you may have heard about it on
the radio or no that has something to do
with the stock market but what exactly
is Nasdaq and what does it do make sure
to stick around to the end to find out
[Music]
welcome to Hari saw B's Nasdaq is a
global electronic marketplace for buying
and selling securities it is also a
benchmark index for US stocks it stands
for National Association of Securities
Dealers automated quotations in essence
it is a platform on which people trade
stocks so how exactly does not stack
work well next I can also exchange of
stocks between buyers and sellers using
highly remarkable and reliable computers
there are three main parts that make up
the Nasdaq Stock Exchange the first of
which is that interface this is simply
the place where broker dealers and
traffic controllers gain access to
system the second part is the matching
system this is a system that matches
buyers and sellers when their prices
match for example let's say a lowest
selling price for a specific stock is
100 shares for $11 for share and the
highest buying price is $10
80 cents for 50 shares at this point the
matching system will determine that
there are no matches and a bargain
sellers will have to continue to wait
but knowledge there is a new buyer who's
willing to pay at eleven dollars and
five cents per share for 50 shares the
computer will match this person with the
person who is planning to sell a hundred
shares for eleven dollars each and the
buyer will only had to pay $11 per share
and both parties are happy the seller
will be able to sell half of his shares
for the price that he wanted to and the
buyer will get a slight discount than
what he was willing to pay for it
that last and most complex part is court
services code services uses supply and
demand and current pricing information
along with several complex algorithms
and matching engine data to provide up
to a minute price data to the world
that's a very simplified version of what
the Nasdaq platform does and as you can
already see it's very similar to the New
York Stock Exchange
but why was Nasdaq M established if it's
so similar to a New York Stock Exchange
well when Nasdaq was established it was
first recognized electronic stock market
in other words you don't have to go to a
physical location in order to trade
stocks like we're the New York Stock
Exchange NASDAQ traffic controllers are
known as market makers and actively buy
and sell stock on behalf of traders New
York Stock Exchange traffic controllers
on the other hand are known as
specialists they said opening price
super stocks accept limit orders and
moderate interest on particular stocks
Nasdaq market makers like the name
suggest create a full market while New
York Stock Exchange specialists simply
facilitate a market Nasdaq is also more
computerized in the New York Stock
Exchange about 40% of volume that is
traded through Nasdaq is done through
ECNs
or electronic communication networks
only about 7% of blindness traded on the
New York Stock Exchange is done through
easy ends there are also huge listing
requirement differences between the two
to lists on NASDAQ a company must offer
1.25 million shares for the public to
trade but a company listing on the New
York Stock Exchange must only have 1.1
million shares that are held by at least
400 shareholders also New York Stock
Exchange listed companies must have at
least a per share value of $4 and a
market value of at least 40 million
dollars you need a lot more upfront
capital in order to be able to list on
the New York Stock Exchange
there is about a 500,000 dollar fee to
enter the New York Stock Exchange
there's only a 50 to $75 fee to enter
Nasdaq caliber but there is a yearly fee
of about 27 thousand dollars another
difference between two is a type of
stocks that are generally listed on them
the New York Stock Exchange generally
has more stable and less volatile stocks
than Nasdaq for example the New York
Stock Exchange has stock from companies
such as coca-cola Walmart and Citigroup
which are unlikely to change a whole lot
in a given day NASDAQ stocks on the
other hand are usually tech companies
that can fluctuate a law in a given day
like Facebook Apple Google and Amazon
Apple stock may soar the day before an
iPhone release but then plummet if there
are disappointing sales so NASDAQ stocks
are generally more volatile so this is
where you want a good for try to make it
quick but it makes
look out for those short-term capital
gain taxes which can be quite high
that's just the first part of Nasdaq
though there's also Nasdaq Composite and
Nasdaq 100 now as a composite is a
benchmark index or like Dow Jones but
there are a couple differences
first of all Nasdaq index values created
from a lot more company than Dow Jones
which will only based on 30 companies
Dow Jones Industrial Average tracks at
top 30 countries in the respective
industries most of these companies are
traded on the New York Stock Exchange
and only a couple are traded on NASDAQ
these companies include Apple Cisco
Intel and Microsoft Nasdaq Composite on
the other hand tracks all of the
companies that are traded on the Nasdaq
platform most of the countries that make
up the Nasdaq Composite for technology
and Internet related companies one
similarity between the two these
investors cannot trade Dow Jones or the
Nasdaq Composite but they can buy index
fonts or exchange-traded funds that
track either one Nasdaq 100 is a stock
market index made up of 103 equity
securities Nasdaq Composite and Nasdaq
100 are simply stock market indices like
S&P 500 or Dow Jones now don't mess this
up with n deck which to actually stock
that you can buy and DAC is a stock of
the company that manages the Nasdaq
platform now it is a big beautiful buy
and act doctor you were essentially
buying stock of a company that makes
money for people like you buying stock
of other companies and you can bet that
Nasdaq also makes money on buying and
selling fees when you buy your stock
considering that Nasdaq is computerized
have there ever been big issues for the
whole system of shut down and answer to
that is yes but it is very very rare the
last time that Nasdaq shut down due to
computer related issues was on August
22nd 2013 so clearly a while ago and
even during the shutdown it was only
shut down for a total of three hours and
11 minutes a very short period of time
as a result other than such rare
occurrences the system is very reliable
in the end when someone is referred
back they referred to one of three
things they may be referred to a nasdaq
security exchange platform in which
company stock is traded or they may be
referring to end AK which is the stock
of the company that owns the Nasdaq
platform but they are probably referring
to Nasdaq Composite and the state of the
market as a whole so next time you hear
about or see Nasdaq you have a good idea
of what they're talking about but that's
what I have for you guys are Nasdaq
there's something very crucial about
Nasdaq Richard come that down below also
make sure come out what companies you
would like me to cover next if you like
severely drop a like and consider
subscribing you might see more videos
just like this one
well then I'm Laurie I'll see you guys
on the next one